[Musique]
créée de toutes pièces sur des terrains
gagnés sur la mer le port de keroman
conçu équipés spécialement pour la pêche
et le plus moderne de france il est
devenu le second après boulogne pour le
tonnage du poisson frais débarqué au
transbordement du poisson depuis les
chalutiers sa commercialisation et son
expédition se font rapidement
[Applaudissements]
c'est à la fin de la nuit et le matin
très tôt que toute cette partie de la
ville s'anime
les équipages des chalutiers reste
environ 13 jours en mer pendant les
marais régulière il pêche
essentiellement du lieu noir des merlus
merluchon de la morue et de la julienne
les marins ont l'habitude au retour à
terre de garder une grande variété de
poissons frais avec laquelle ils font la
fameuse côte et ryad et cotriade à la
fois souple et plat de résistance
équivalent morbihannais de la
bouillabaisse provençal c'est quoi une
cotriade une sélection de poisson quand
on fait cuire 20 à grand-bassin compte
en suivant la suivons le nombre de
clients si c'est un équipage de 2,6 ou
comme dans le temps à la sardine où nous
étions visés 12 quoi et qu'est ce qu'il
ya comme poisson alors ici il ya s'en
sort il ya du merlu de la julienne la
morue de la rascasse du grondin et
quelques maquereaux vous coupez envers
le entre en jeu ne faut pas couper des
tranches trop épaisses sont quand même
bien pu apprécier autrement
ryan certaine épaisseur premier temps
entre 2 et 3 cm la tranche c'est le
meilleur moyen pour la bonne marchandise
exister alors imparfaite grèce de
françois g ou 159 aller là dedans alors
une fois guy desbiens bien fondu hormel
des oignons coupés alors une fois que
tout ça est dans la joute de l'eau habib
à sainte foy où il ya trop de rouge non
plus puisque autrement le mouillé on
n'aura pas de force seront pas tellement
bon quoi sitôt que le bouillon un prix
clair on met dans le récipient les
pommes de terre coupées en morceaux et
une fois que ça bout on le sent mieux
bouillir à peu près instant mais le
poisson pour bien le saisir vos propos
que ça fasse de la marmelade et trop
qu'on puisse déguster le cochon après
quoi les têtes dans le fond c'est ce
sont les pièces des plus résistantes et
voulait laisser combien de temps à moins
d'une minute dix minutes un quart
d'heure quoi mais ça dépend du bouillon
york puisque quelques fois ça beau galop
mais faut pas d'abord que ça ça vous
trop longtemps galop et bien que dollar
est descendu le son sort de l'art et du
poison
ça y est c'est cuit quoi voilà dit non
ça va être un super juge assez il faut
respecter le poids sans quoi la cotriade
pour nous c'est sacré c'est une forme
avancée par great qu'on voulait et le
rite consiste également à manger cette
cotriade entre pêcheurs du même équipage
dans le bistrot du port préparé par le
cuistot du chalutier
le poisson est enlevée du bouillon et se
mange chaud avec une vinaigrette place
ou que l'on trempe se consolent selon la
tradition en deuxième position
mais nous avons un excellent guide et
chacun de commenter la variété des
odeurs et la saveur des poissons
spontanément à tour de rôle on les
marins chanteurs ont une chanson reprise
en choeur par tous les autres sortes de
complaintes où il est toujours question
de femmes qui attendent et de mères qui
pleurent veux chanter chanter dans le
rsa lui le débat jamais lassé sur
l'aviron des souks et le grand bol il
leur dit tout
entre deux
[Musique]